نبدأ بالتقرير الذي طال انتظاره حول أصول جائحة covet 19 وقد حصلت CNN على نسخة مسودة من التقرير الذي يقول إن الفيروس جاء على الأرجح من حيوانات وليس معملًا في الصين. المصادر المحتملة للفيروس يقولون إنه على الأرجح ينتشر من خلال مضيف حيواني وسيط ربما يكون حيوانًا بريًا تم أسره وتربيته في مزرعة أو انتقال مباشر من حيوان معروف أنه يحمل فيروسًا مشابهًا لفيروس كورونا مثل البنغول أو الخفافيش ، يقول التقرير إنه ليس كذلك من المحتمل أن تكون قد أتت من الأطعمة المجمدة والمصدر الأقل احتمالية يقولون إن تسرب المختبر جيدًا لمزيد من المعلومات حول هذا التقرير ، دعنا ننتقل الآن إلى cnn's christy loostout تنضم إلينا على الهواء مباشرة من هونغ كونغ جيدًا لرؤيتك كريستي فماذا فعلت هذا التقرير أيضًا الكشف عن أصول covet 19 ومدى موثوقية النتائج نظرًا للقيود المفروضة على الفريق بعد عام واحد من بدء الوباء ، أنت على حق روزيما  هناك الكثير من المخاوف
بشأن توقيت
عملية الوصول والمنهجية التي
دخلت في هذا التحقيق
حصلت CNN على مسودة من
تقرير 123 صفحة من قبل منظمة الصحة العالمية
التي
تبحث في أصول
فيروس كورونا الجديد ، وهناك الكثير من التفاصيل
هناك  كما يمكنك أن تتوقع ولكن لا يوجد
دليل على الأصل
النهائي للوباء الآن وفقًا لهذا
التقرير ، فقد جاء الفيروس على الأرجح من
حيوان وليس من مختبر وفقًا لهذا التقرير
، فمن المرجح أن الفيروس
انتشر ولم ينتشر أكثر من
قبل شهر أو شهرين
من اكتشافه في البداية في كانون الأول (ديسمبر) من
عام
2019. كما أوضحت التقرير يسير عبر
أربعة
مصادر محتملة للفيروس ، المصدر الأرجح
هو مضيف حيوان وسيط
أصيب بخفاش
ولكن الحيوان الذي وفقًا
للتقرير  يبقى اقتباس
بعيد المنال الآن المصدر التالي الأكثر ترجيحًا
هو
الانتقال المباشر من حيوان مثل الخفافيش
أو
البنغول ممكن الآن ولكن ليس من المحتمل أن يكون
حامضًا  وفقًا لهذا
التقرير ،
ينتقل الفيروس من خلال الأطعمة المجمدة أو
الأغذية المجمدة ،
وهي نظرية تم
الترويج لها بنشاط من قبل الصين على مدار العام الماضي
والسيناريو الأقل احتمالية
وفقًا لمن هو التقرير والمسودة التي تم
إصدارها  بالنسبة لنا في وقت مبكر
، تم وصف إصدار مختبري عرضي على
أنه اقتباس غير محتمل للغاية لم يتم اقتباسه من
قبل مؤلفي التقرير
الآن قبل إصدار التقرير.
وهو يركز بشدة على
أسواق الحياة البرية والحياة البرية في الصين ،
واستمع
، وما وجدناه في الصين هو أن هذا
السوق
يبيع المأكولات البحرية ولكنه أيضًا سرق
منتجات الحياة البرية والحياة البرية
وأنت تعرف جثثًا كاملة من الحيوانات
والحيوانات الحية
من أنواع مختلفة من  المزارع في جميع أنحاء
الصين ، لذلك كان هناك بالتأكيد
مسار يأخذ الحيوانات القادمة إلى
هذا السوق من
جميع أنحاء الصين بما في ذلك  الأماكن
التي تم العثور فيها
على أقرب أقرباء sarsko v2
في الخفافيش ، لذا فإن ما وجدناه هو
دليل مهم جدًا على أنها طريقة
يمكن أن ينتقل بها الفيروس من المناطق الريفية
في الصين إلى مدينة كبيرة مثل ووهان وأدى إلى تفشي
بيتر دازك  أكد فريق التحقيق
wjo هناك ما أفادته CNN لأول مرة
في يناير من العام الماضي أن
سوق الباب والمأكولات البحرية في هوانغ
باعوا أكثر من مجرد المأكولات البحرية
والعلامة التجارية الثانية في الحياة البرية
في الصين وفرت مسارًا
لفيروس إكليل الجبل